ARE ALSO DENYING THERE'S SUCH A
THING AS A TRUTH.
>> TULSI GABBARD JOINS US TO
EXPLAIN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, CONGRESS WOMAN.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU STILL WANT
TO BE CALLED THAT, BUT THANKS
FOR BEING HERE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE REACTION OF
YOUR FELLY DEMOCRATS TO YOUR
ANNOUNCEMENT.
WHAT HAS THE REACTION BEEN?
>> I GOT TO BE HONEST, I'VE
HEARD DIRECTLY FROM A COUPLE
THAT HAVE BEEN ENCOURAGING AND
GAVE ME GOOD FEEDBACK.
I'VE HEARD A LOT OF EXPECTED
HATRED AND VITREAL COMING FROM
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY ELITE
TROTTING OUT THE SAME OLD TIRED
CRITICISMS THAT HAVE NOTHING TO
DO WITH SUBSTANCE.
THIS HAS BEEN PART OF THE
PROBLEM ALL ALONG THAT I TALKED
ABOUT IN MY ANNOUNCEMENT, WHY I
LEFT THE PARTY.
THIS PARTY IS NOW CONTROLLED BY
FIN NAT CALL IDEOLOGS THAT DON'T
BELIEVE IN FREEDOM, SEAN.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE WE CAN HAVE
DIFFERENT OPINIONS.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE I, YOU OR
ANYONE SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO
EXPRESS OUR VIEWS IF THEY
DISAPPROVE OF THE VIEWS AND THEY
WILL SEEK TO SMEAR US, CRITICIZE
US, WORK WITH BIG TECH TO CENSOR
US AND SUPPRESS THESE GOD-GIVEN
FREEDOMS THAT ARE ENSHRINED IN
OUR CONSTITUTION.
THE DANGER OF THAT IS, WHEN YOU
HAVE A POLITICAL PARTY THAT DOES
NOT BELIEVE IN FREEDOM, THAT IS
IN POWER, THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO USE THE FORCE OF THE
GOVERNMENT AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO ENFORCE THAT SUPPRESSION AND
THAT UNDERMINING OF OUR
FREEDOMS.
>> Sean: IN THAT SPEECH, I PAID
VERY CLOSE ATTENTION TO WHAT YOU
WERE SAYING.
IT'S CONFIRM OR BE CANCELLED.
YOU SPOKE ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF DEFENDING WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
A WOMAN.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THOSE THAT DENY
BIOLOGICAL DIFFERENCES BETWEEN A
MAN AND A WOMAN ARE NOT ONLY
ERASING WOMAN AS A CATEGORY OF
PEOPLE BUT DENYING THE EXISTENCE
OF OBJECTIVE REALITY AND TRUTH.
YOU EVEN WENT FURTHER.
YOU HAVE WOKE POLITICIANS AND A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE THAT ARE
UNABLE AND UNWILLING TO DEFINE
WHAT A WOMAN IS OR DEFEND
WOMEN'S SPORTS WHEN FEMALE
ATHLETES OBJECT TO COMPETING
AGAINST BIOLOGICAL MALES.
THIS -- YOU THOUGHT LONG, HARD
AND DEEPLY ABOUT THESE POSITIONS
BEFORE YOU DID THIS.
SO WHAT IS THE REACTION TO THAT?
BECAUSE I WOULD IMAGINE IN THIS
WOKE WORLD PROBABLY THAT SPARKED
A LOT OF BACKLASH AND ANGER
ALSO.
>> IT SPARKED A LOT OF BACKLASH
AND ANGER FROM THE EXPECTED
PLACES, THE SO-CALLED WOKE
FANATICAL IDEOLOGS THAT CONTROL
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I GOT A LOT OF MESSAGES FROM
PEOPLE I KNOW AND FROM PEOPLE I
NEVER MET THAT EXPRESSED HOPE IN
THEIR REACTION, WHO FELT
EMBOLDENED AND INSPIRED THAT
THEY TOO DON'T HAVE TO
SELF-CENSOR AND COWER IN THE
CORNER FOR FEAR OF BEING
CANCELLED OR LOSE THEIR JOB.
WE NEED MORE PEOPLE TO STEP UP
TO BELIEVE IN OUR FREEDOM OF
SPEECH, WE HAVE TO STEP UP AND
USE IT AND GO OUT AND VOTE
ACCORDINGLY IN THIS NEXT
ELECTION, WHICH IS WHY I INVITED
DEMOCRATS THAT FEEL AS SICKENED
AS I DO ABOUT TODAY'S DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, LEAVE AND MOVE FORWARD
AND PUT OUR COUNTRY FIRST.
>> Sean: LET'S TALK ABOUT YOU
AND WHAT LED UP TO THIS DECISION
AND HOW DO YOU NOW DEFINE
YOURSELF POLITICALLY AND DO YOU
HAVE POLITICAL AMBITIONS MOVING
FORWARD?
>> I AM AN INDEPENDENT.
I AM FOCUSED ON TWO MAIN THINGS.
IT IS CONTINUING TO FIGHT FOR
THE FREEDOMS THAT ARE UNDER
ATTACK IN THIS COUNTRY AND
CONTINUING TO HOLD OUR LEADERS'
FEET TO THE FIRE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND HIS ALLIES
IN CONGRESS THAT ARE PUSHING UP
TO THE BRINK OF NUCLEAR WAR,
PLACING OUR FUTURE, THE FUTURE
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, HUMANITY
AND THE WORLD AT RISK.
THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT I'M
ASKING VOTERS TO CONSIDER AS
THEY GO TOWARDS THE POLLS
BECAUSE IF WE DO NOTHING, IF WE
STAND BY AND ALLOW THE PRESIDENT
TO CONTINUE TO PUSH US OVER THE
BRINK OF NUCLEAR WAR, WE MAY NOT
SEE A TOMORROW OR NEXT MONTH OR
NEXT YEAR.
THESE ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: PEOPLE HAVE CRITICIZED
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN UKRAINE AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN, ET CETERA.
VLADIMIR PUTIN NOW IS BOMBING
CIVILIAN TARGETS
INDISCRIMINATELY.
KILLING INNOCENT MEN, WOMEN AND
CHILDREN.
IT SHOULD BE WESTERN EUROPE'S
PROBLEM MORE THAN OURS.
THEY'RE NOT A MEMBER OF NATO,
UKRAINE.
AND NOW HE'S THREATENING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS WHAT
SHOULD AMERICA'S ROLE IN THE
WORLD BE WHEN YOU HAVE A HOSTILE
ACTOR, A THUG AND MURDERER OF
INNOCENT MEN AND CHILDREN, IN
THIS CASE, PUTIN.
WHAT SHOULD AMERICA'S REACTION
BE?
HOW SHOULD -- DO WE STAND BY AND
SAY THAT'S YOUR PROBLEM OR DO WE
HAVE A MORALE OBLIGATION TO SAY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LET ANYBODY
KILL INNOCENT MEN, WOMEN AND
CHILDREN?
>> FIRST I'LL SAY PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS BEEN ENACTING POLICIES
AND ACTIONS THAT HAVE FURTHER
ESCALATED THIS WAR RATHER THAN
EXERCISES THE OPPORTUNITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY HE HAS AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO WORK TO BRING THESE PARTIES
TOGETHER, DEESCALATE AND COME TO
A NEGOTIATED PEACEFUL SOLUTION.
SOME SAY TULSI, THAT IS
IMPOSSIBLE.
LY POINT THOSE PEOPLE BACK TO
THE WORDS THAT WAS KENNEDY
GAVE --
>> Sean: WE CAN HAVE A DIALOGUE
ABOUT IT.
HE INVADED A SOVEREIGN COUNTRY.
HE'S CLAIMING IT TO BE HIS OWN.
IF ANYONE SAID HAWAII IS OURS, I
THINK I KNOW IT'S YOUR HOME
STATE, YOU WOULD NOT LIKE THAT
AND WANT AMERICA TO DEFEND YOU.
>> HAWAII IS PART OF THE UNITED
STATES.
THAT WOULD BE A PROBLEM.
>> Sean: ONE OF THE NICEST
PARTS.
YOU'RE SEPARATE AND APART.
I DON'T BLAME YOU.
BUT ONCE SOMEBODY INVADES A
COUNTRY AND KILLS INNOCENT MEN,
WOMEN AND CHILDREN, DOES THE
WORLD HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO STOP
IT EARLY OR DO YOU GIVE IN TO
NUCLEAR BLACKMAIL?
SOMEBODY COULD SAY I'M GOING TO
NUKE YOU IF YOU DARE SUPPORT
UKRAINE OR WHATEVER COUNTRY IT
HAPPENS TO BE.
>> THE PATH WE'RE ON --
>> I'M NOT ASKING YOU THAT.
>> LET ME ANSWER HERE, SEAN.
>> Sean: I HAVE A HARD TIME --
>> IN THE MORAL OBLIGATION IS TO
DO WHAT WE CAN TO END THE
SUFFERING OF THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE, IT'S TO BRING ABOUT AN
END TO THIS WAR AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS FAILED TO DO
THAT.
HE HAS FAILED THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THE PEOPLE OF UKRAINE
AND THE WORLD IN DOING THAT.
>> Sean: TULSI, THAN